we're all human
we all make mistakes
it's just that in this line of work the
consequences of those mistakes are
simply more consequential what is your
take on it what do you think my take on
him is that
um
it was not intentional
he he was not conscious of his own guilt
sir there's a lot of bleeding focus on
your job
i take at face value that christopher
dunch believes that he was a brilliant
surgeon and he believes that he was hard
done by by the medical system and
ultimately the legal system
and he believes that he's the hero of
his own story he's a terrifying case
study of how a system breaks down and
instead of self-correcting just
continues to double down on its own
mistake i'm sure people will will be
debating that yeah forever and
everything
and the truth is we don't make the
choice for you right and it should be
debated because it is debatable if at
any moment
you feel uncomfortable we're going after
dun she win you're like a restless
toddler the cast in this in addition to
yourself
phenomenal and amazing to see alec
baldwin and christian slater on screen
together going back and forth what's
that like for you to see the two of them
going at it is just so much fun but also
turns out they're a great comedy team
who knew
like you never know when you put two
axes together if the thing is going to
work if the chemistry is going to be
there but those guys
nailed it we need it the team of baldwin
and slater totally like we talked about
it all the time on set once it was so
clear that these guys were kind of
stealing the show we were like this
needs to be a show by itself like the
the it's all well and good this dunch
stuff but what we really need is we need
to send like youtube need to buddy
comedy on the road forever you gave us
so much with uh with dr death but one
thing it took from us i think was the
opportunity to see you as a cameo in the
mighty ducks game changers they did come
to me for season one but i was not only
just doing this show but doing the show
and during the covert period there was
just no way to travel and get that done
so it may come back around but the
answer is i don't know